本日はハードル一つはです
あの
3月が
終わりましたあのとてもありがたいことに動画外の活動がすごく多いんですよという
ことでちょっと3月もいろいろなことをしてあの
書付き
なかなか休み時間なかったんですよある一にず休みなんてまずね言えばないんですから
ねそんな中私は3月かけ走った結果なんですけども体がめちゃくちゃヤバイことになっ
てしまいますか
まず腕ですそっから見えるか分からないですけど
これで美味いからだった気がするんですよね腕の付け根がめちゃくちゃ
加瀬ましたこれだけだったら別に前といっしょ出し動画にする必要ないと思ったんです
けどもさらに追加で体に異常が起きました
こちら商品紹介見てやってますけど結構痛いじゃあこっちは相当ボロボロになってるね
ことはわかりづらいから
つけるとこちらの日ですねここがも
あのねぇ
痛いです
[音楽]
はっはっは
自分じゃ見え自分じゃばいいんですけどどうですか足のここもボロプロなんてなんでも
出血とかしてるんですよなぁこれだとわかりやすいかなもう相当ボロボロすねからだ
パラボラねなんでこれ動画にしようと思ったかといいますとなんかね前田とはかゆい
ですんでたんですよ
痒いですんでたんですけども今回痛いんですよ痛い歩いても痛いからね
ができればね足を曲げたくない曲げとピリピリしていたりしてだねっていう時にも無
意識に掻いてるみたいでなんか血が出たりしちゃってて前回病院に行った時聞いたのは
搬送波なきゃいいって言われたんですけども
させに乾燥肌で書いて痛みが出たり
こんなに悪化することってあると思いましてわかんないです何が原因か分からないん
ですけどちょっともう一回病院にちゃんと聞いて行
どうかと思います皆にをやれたんですけどパッと見てっぱん目に入っ2ぐらいちょっと
悪化してきたんでさすがにこれ映像に映る人間ってちょっと直さなきゃと思いまして
ちょっとまだまだ忙しいんですけどなんとか今日時間があるみたいなんで病院に行って
きます
先ほどでましたら1時間待つと言われました
行ってきます
[音楽]
ただいまで3位というわけで帰ってまいりますねちょっともう痛くて痒くて同情もなっ
てすぐ曲がその場で塗ったんですけどちょっとしろーくなってるんですけど薬は塗らせ
ていただきました
ここはもう水ややばいだもうなんかやけどみたいだってねあいついうわけでちょっとお
医者さんと離さ内容をまとめてみますえっとですね前へちょっとちょっと話が変わって
きまして前行った時はね本当にただの季節的な乾燥肌で早くになっちゃって書きまくっ
てこうなってるよって言われたんですけども今回ちょっと別なこと言われて汗がに乾燥
肌でこんなひどいことにはならないって言われてお医者さんの予想だとあ分アトピーも
ちょっとアレじゃないかという結果をいただきましたんですよね普通に乾燥肌だけで
こんなに
分
うん的じゃね涸沢たっても体全体のことになり何かこんなね直腸て気になるのは
おかしいんでどうやらちょっとただの勘坂のとは違うんじゃないかという話をいただき
ました
いやー圧迫すると鍵も痒いですね結構ちなみに十三みたいでここまで酷くなっているの
かみたいな言われ方をしたので結構もうヤバイ状態ですねうーだっていく時間でも僕の
姉と最速でいきました
オックス
よねなんかたくさんもらってきたんですよねたぶんでよく聞く奴なんですけどね知る
どういうとってとっ
ご期待ですね
[音楽]
いう使い方があるみたいなんですけどよく聞きますにヒルドイドって波ね
おくすり手帳を作ってもらいました僕基本病院行きたくないんですよあんま好きじゃ
なくて言っちゃいけないけど行かざるを得ない状況に追い込まれるって事は相当なん
ですけどマジでかよかったか嫌すぎるのと思いたいので結構ね限界レベルだったんで
もし同じ症状とかかよかったで年でる人がいたらまず
すぐ入った方がいいと思いますドックてリーガで2つございました郵政クリームって
書いたんですけど
な族に皆さんがよく使っている保湿クリームの最強がみたいなもんです
本当にこれこれは薬剤師の人にも言われたんですけど1日に何回使用容量ないらしいん
でもう何回も塗っちゃっていいらしいですねお医者さんに僕言われたんですよ
あのあなたに足りないのは保湿だって言っ中ですねぼく毎日保湿クリーム塗ってるん
ですよこそスクリームってでもで毎日塗ってりゃいいってもんじゃなくて保湿クリーム
を塗るのが目的じゃなくて保湿クリームを
塗って保湿できているかどうかが大事らしいです今すごい自分の事いいましたよどう
いうことかと言いますと
や人によって他の肌が乾燥しやすい飛ばすにくいとか春らしくて僕はめちゃくちゃ
カートしやすい方なんて超乾燥肌なんで人によっては1日1回の保湿クリームを塗る量
でいい人いるし
乾燥しやすい人はあの日本当にひどいとは1日10回
から1日10回ぐらい保湿クリームを塗らなきゃいけない人もいるらしいんですよなん
でね僕がね1日1回保湿クリームつけたところで実際は保湿はできてない見たかった
ですね以上に風呂上がりに塗るときはいいやと思ってるんですけどもそれだと全然た
ないみたいで
つーわけでもこのクリームは本当すきやリア塗ってくれって言われたんで僕しばらく
ベタベタしてますよろしくお願いします某塗りすぎでいいらしいですね本当に肌を潤わ
せること
が大事らしいんですごい勉強になりましたなんか前のお医者さんすごかったですけど
今回のお医者さんを説得力があったというかねあと b かどうかまだ分からない
らしいんですけど原因がまずは現状のこのひどい状態
ここどことこのここでひどい状況なお指定からまたちょっとこういうことまだならない
ように考えましょうって感じで
ゲイ
じゃあ今の肌の状態を治すことと言われました
これが最強の保湿クリームで骨型のヒルドイド1日2回しか使っちゃダメって言われた
んでこれたらめっちゃ強いやつです
いやー
来栖いねえかゆいのマジで苦しいさあ気持ちがついつい書くと止まんなくなっちゃう
から
苦しいってかつでも辛い思いをしておりました
ネ申きゅりあんぬローマ字で本当に
[音楽]
ブービーの可能性が出てきたっていうと結局保湿ですね保湿が大事です頑張ってほしい
としまっくって肌のペロ
あげて言ってそっからアトピーをどう小学放ちになってくるらしいですが見た目だけで
もちょっと直したいだと思っておりますやと痒いのがやっぱ辛い
早く完治できるように頑張りますじゃあ
me
ええええええ
あっはっ